hey thanks to quip for sponsoring a
portion of this video you know good
health starts with good habits quit
makes it easy by delivering all the oral
care essentials you need to care for
your mouth you know what i love about
quip
there's a built-in two-minute timer that
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides and to help you
clean your whole mouth evenly why
because up to 90 of us don't brush for a
full two minutes or don't clean evenly
you know what else i love with quip you
can earn points and rewards just for
brushing your teeth two minutes per day
twice a day yup you heard me right
with stylish and affordable electric
brushes starting at just 25
you won't be paying through the teeth
for better oral health
you see what i did there
if you go to get quit dot com start talk
right now you'll get your first refill
free that's your first refill free at
get quick dot com slash start talk g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash start talk
clip the good habits company
[Music]
sure
hey
how much you know about the moon
well i didn't know there was going to be
a quiz right off the bat
no math no math in this quiz no math in
this okay yeah i just want to mention a
few things some of this might have
slipped out in previous explainers
and so i just want to say
the full moon
all right
doesn't have extra gravity compared to
any other phase of the moon oh
well
you are now
going against what most people will say
on you know the tide is higher because
it's a full moon well so where they'll
say you know this is why it's an
explainer video
set the record straight so we can go
back to newton on this and you learn
that the strength of gravity relates to
only two things
how much mass
there is and that stays the same for the
moon no matter what
and how far away it is right
it only relates to those two variables
and the moon while its orbit is slightly
oval
um that's not correlated with the phase
so
um the phase of the moon does not affect
how much gravity the moon is exerting on
earth at all
ah
so when people say
the tides are high during a full moon by
the way the tides are also high
during a new moon okay but no one
mentions they're equally as high as they
are during a full moon that's my first
point second the low tides during a full
moon
are the lowest tides of the month
wow right
so what's happening is no one ever talks
about this the sun has tides on the
earth also
aha okay but they're like a third the
strength of the moon's tides so people
don't think about it as often as they
think about the moon's tides now watch
watch every day there are high tides and
low tides right but at full moon the
high tide is higher
and the low tide is lower than at any
other time of month same with the new
moon so why
it's because when you have full moon
the sun is exactly aligned
with the earth moon system
okay and so the sun's tides add
to the moon's tides
right
okay yes so the sun is
pulling along with a long width so the
moose tides which are constant the whole
month
now get an added bonus because the sun's
tides which
give a little bit of a rise that rise is
added to the moon's rise and then you
get extra high tides wow it's not
because of the moon it's because the sun
aligns with the moon
it should be called the sunta i mean
this is the sun high tide thank you
that's really because it's the sun's
fault right that's why that's happening
now when the sun's tides align at right
angles
to the moon's tides that's when the moon
is in first quarter or third or half
moon all right when it's at right angles
then the high tide
conflicts of the sun conflicts with the
high tide of the moon they compete with
each other then you get what they call
neap tides which are not the the high
tide is the lowest of the month so
that's what's just going on there and
people i just want to put that out there
in case people were wondering because
people say oh the full moon because of
the tides it must be affecting us in
some extra way
you know i i don't know what storm we
had um this wasn't recent but there was
a full moon and we had uh this terrible
storm and everybody was like well you
know it's because the moon was full and
so that's why there was so much flooding
well no it's well it's because the sun
was aligned with the moon so the high
tide was even higher right but that's
too much to say and people it's not easy
to remember
and so
but what i'm saying is it wasn't the
moon it was the sun the sun correct
correct
don't blame the moon
okay so now okay
how about other things that happen to
people under moonlight
like
werewolves
we've all seen the movies
somebody's out and they're we're wolf
sensitive let's say okay and they're out
and then the clouds part
and then there's the full moon and they
see it and then they become a werewolf
okay yes exactly okay so what made them
a werewolf was it the full moon just
tell me in the movie what made them a
werewolf well it was the exposure to the
full moon okay okay so they see it and
they're like ah
okay so wait a minute so that means they
don't become a werewolf in the basement
i know well yes you're right why
wouldn't you just stay home okay well so
a if you have to see the full moon you
gotta see it if you're gonna see it so
that means when you're in the basement
you're not becoming a werewolf even
though it's full moon it means
if it's overcast
at night it could be a full moon and
you're not going to become a werewolf
okay
so that's interesting to me so it means
they're reacting to the light of the
moon okay okay
now i did an experiment in eighth grade
science for an eighth grade science fair
okay i came in second place um i took
spectra of the moon with a spectroscope
that i built okay from scratch and that
was second place yeah second place okay
what the hell won a tiny nuclear reactor
what the
kind of school did you go to
no so i don't think they well
a biology experiment won it someone did
experiments on seeds uh that's fine i
didn't have this wasn't defining my life
but what i'm saying is if you look at
the spectrum of the moon
it is exactly equal to the spectrum of
the sun
so all of the light the quality of the
light the source of the light the
balance of the light that comes from the
moon
started from the sun
and reflects off the moon back to you
so if a full moon turns you into a
werewolf
so too should be the sun
in broad daylight so shoot to that turn
you into a werewolf but they don't
right
yeah
now now in the bible in genesis there's
reference to the moon lighting the night
right okay as like a separate thing
going on from the sun lighting the day
for that reason and for others for the
longest time
people
believed that the moon was its own
source of light right if that were the
case you could say moonlight is special
and that's what's affecting me turning
me into a werewolf
but it's not the source of its own light
it just reflects the sun and so you got
no argument
wow look at that and because they're
looking at the moon and they're not
feeling the tidal forces of the moon
plus the sun because if that were the
case they would turn it to willows in
their basement or on cloudy nights but
they don't
for that case it's the light and it's
the same light as the sun just wanna
make that clear okay and the sun is of
course much brighter than the moon so if
anybody had any tinge a possibility of
turning into a werewolf a full broad
daylight sun would do it like that you'd
be extra werewolfy next to it okay so
the moon there's so much lore about the
moon it's a beautiful thing it's been
with us from the beginning and i love it
it's cultural but it's not factual and
the idea that people would act crazy
under a full moon uh the police
department's report increased crime if
they're under a full moon and that's
when they noticed that there was a full
moon and by the way there's about four
or five days where the moon is close
enough to being full that the average
person would call it a full moon yes
okay so you gotta five days that's one
out of six days in the month
you're going to be able to blame
something on the full moon okay that's
something that goes wrong over that time
the funny thing is people have the
expectation that you're supposed to act
crazy and the full moon rises at sunset
and sets at sunrise right other phases
of the moon don't do that that this foom
is the only moon that's a phase that's
up all night
so whatever time you staggered out of
the bar the full moon is up right and
that's really the deal right that's
really what's going on and you're okay
until you stagger out of the bar and
then he's all a full moon then you start
acting crazy you fulfill
the the expectations that literature has
provided for us
simply being prophesied fulfilling
prophecy of the full moon and jack
daniels
got a feeling that might have a little
something to do with it
so anyhow there's a little bit of moon
lore people love the moon during
halloween yeah and
nobody doesn't love the moon so i'm just
a tip our hat to the moon for all roles
it has played in our culture
in our storytelling
and when i do see werewolf movies i'm
all in you know i'm not one of the other
would never happen no i'm all with it
but i do like some consistency in the
storyline that's all yeah well i just
can't believe we got through this whole
talk without me making one butt joke
so why oh to moon oh okay sorry sorry my
brain wasn't in that spot i'm sorry
right because when you said what do you
know about the moon i was just going to
say well you stick it out the windows
when you're moving wait where you on the
highway
a lot of ways one of the best things
ever do i'm sorry
oh really really okay yeah yeah
if you're eight years old yes chuck but
you're a grown man with married with
children okay well that's that's even
better to have them in the car while you
do it
dad again
jesus
okay all right there's way more i could
talk about the moon but we'll save that
for another uh put that in another
explainer okay but anyway chuck good to
have you always a pleasure all right
everybody this has been star talk one of
our
stuff we thought you should know
explainer videos neil degrasse tyson
here keep looking up
you